I'm waiting to sort of officially join
but I'm really hoping to be involved yes
well it's finally official Paris Geller
is back according to variety Liza Wheel
is joining the Gilmore Girls Netflix
reboot and last month she dished et all
about some ideas she already has up her
sleeve what do you want to see Paris
doing I'm just sort of excited to see
these people in any capacity again so
the prospect is sort of being back on
that lot and in those sets and with
those people again that's kind of a big
wish fulfillment so anything beyond that
is you know what would her and Rory be
like as moms together do you think
that's a possibility
it's certainly a possibility yeah I
don't hate you know it's really hard
yeah whether mommy hood is in the
picture or not one thing is for sure
Liza thinks the former frenemies will be
in a very similar spot to where we left
off I think that our dynamic is probably
similar to where we left them I think
that they are close at times and they
probably you know butt heads on on
something soon as well